wir
freuen uns jetzt auf den sommer und wir
alle haben machen uns sorgen
wegen des ukraine krieges aber es gibt
ja auch noch corona das ist ja nicht weg
der herbst wird kommen das steht fest
und es ist sicher nützlich zu wissen wie
wir uns eigentlich geschlagen haben in
der pandemie wie die sogenannte
maßnahmen gewirkt haben was war richtig
was wir falsch was war übertrieben und
um das herauszufinden
tut die regierung das was nach jedem
seminar gemacht wird eine evaluation
wird gestartet als unabhängige experten
schauen sie sich das an unabhängige und
bilden sich ein urteil darüber und sehr
sinnvoll und das will karl lauterbach
der gesundheitsminister offenbar nicht
er hat einen brief geschrieben an die
bundestagspräsidentin er sagt
dass es um über die maßnahmen so erleben
das nicht in bausch und bogen habt nur
den teil in dem es um die maßnahmen geht
damit meine ich lockdown
schulschließungen und dergleichen
um die maßnahmen wirklich beurteilen zu
können viele die datenbasis und deswegen
sollte man doch bitte diese das
veröffentlichung dieser evaluation
mindestens auf den sommer 2023 schieben
ein jahr warum die daten die jetzt
angeblich nicht da sind 2023 plötzlich
da sein sollen weiß ich auch nicht aber
für herrn lauterbach wäre eine solche
verschiebung natürlich unglaublich
praktisch denn der herbst kann kommen er
kann wieder für schulschließungen und
harte maßnahmen trommeln das macht er
gerne das ist so seinem stil gewesen
letzter in den letzten jahren ohne dass
irgend ein unabhängiges gremium mal
genau drauf geguckt hätte was das
wirklich bringt was er da alles will und
das kommt dazu er kann sich schon
vorstellen
was in dieser evaluation stehen wird
unser nachbarland die schweiz hat
nämlich schon eine gemacht deutschland
ist ja recht oft ein bisschen langsam
auch in diesem fall war es dass die
schweiz erwartet nella haben evaluiert
und was kam dabei heraus vor allem die
schulschließungen seien nicht
verhältnismäßig gewesen weil der nutzen
den sie für die pandemie bekämpfung
gehabt haben in gar keinem verhältnis
stand zu dem schaden den die
bildungsbiografien von kindern und
jugendlichen haben das befürchtet
lauterbach glaube ich wird auch in der
deutschen evaluation stehen und das
sollen die leute natürlich möglichst
erst 2023 erfahren nachdem herr
lauterbach den schulen vielleicht wieder
mal dicht gemacht hat aber es gibt noch
ein eine sache muss ich noch sagen weil
das ist an dieser ganzen geschichte für
mich das gruseligste und sonderbarsten
wer sitzt in dieser unabhängigen
kommission die von außen auf das werk
der regierung blicken soll es sollte
darin sitzen der virologe der maßgeblich
diese maßnahmen beeinflusst hat der
wichtigste ratgeber dieser politik
nämlich herr droste der sitzt also da
und soll sich sein eigenes schulzeugnis
schreiben das war die idee die idee ist
nicht aufgegangen weil wolfgang kubicki
einen neuen trend brief geschrieben hat
gegen diese sache ist ja jurist und er
sagt dass also es gibt ja auch so was
wie unabhängigkeit und unbefangenheit
und das ist ja hier in diesem fall
überhaupt nicht gegeben haben also ist
hat es gibt es das geplatzt aber herr
lauterbach finde das sehr schade dabei
brauchen wir so eine evaluation ja gar
nicht wenn wir ja wir bauen nur in
unsere nachbarländer zu gucken sie haben
die schweiz genannt wir haben ja noch
dänemark die haben dann die kinder keine
masken getragen in der schule schweden
und dann gucken uns die zahlen an und
das ist auch nicht in ein mensch mehr
gestorben als bei uns also diese
gründung fand ich schon immer ein
bisschen fadenscheinig muss natürlich
schauen was das für ein virus ist mit
denen wir es im herbst zu tun haben das
weiß aber niemand niemand weiß dass ein
killervirus wie der gesundheitsminister
gerade ist er noch der geeignete
gesundheitsminister frau raffelhüschen
für dieses land das ja nicht nur corona
als problem im gesundheitsministerium
kennt sonne ja viele viele andere
probleme noch
ist gemeinde so nicht passiert weil zu
laut aber habe ich ein ganz spezielles
verhältnis auf was so gesundheitspolitik
vorher schon
anbelangt hat und ich sehe in ihm jemand
der dieses thema lebt der sich damit
profiliert und jetzt sehen wir es
bröckelt ja also wir tragen keine masken
mehr und ich spüre irgendwie dass das
ihm so sein kind abhandenkommt und das
ärgert mich ein bisschen also die
rationalität
fehlt mir her und
hat auch ihn als experten
auszuweisen nur weil er in harvard
gesundheitsökonomie studiert hat das hat
mich auch immer gestört dieses harvard
und ja also ich persönlich hätte mir
jemand anderen gewünscht also
er war ja während der kroner phase
wirklich gerade am ende so eine art
alarm oder angst minister und man hat
teilweise den eindruck gehabt als dann
das thema corona nicht mehr so in der
öffentlichkeit war dann hat er auch so
ein bisschen darunter gelitten weil er
selber nicht mehr so in der
öffentlichkeit war und das ist natürlich
für einen minister immer schlechten
minister muss sagen ich kümmere mich um
die probleme die das land hat und
versuche in meinem bereich das
bestmögliche zu tun aber das darf kein
selbstzweck sein dass so ein thema einer
nach vorne spielt dass es das eine das
andere ist das ja auch bedeutende
virologen in deutschland wie zum
beispiel hendrik streek immer wieder
darauf hingewiesen haben dass wir
natürlich einerseits
virologisch das ganze betrachten müssen
aber immer auch andere perspektiven
einnehmen müssen zum beispiel welche
kollateralschäden gibt es für
jugendliche für kinder für
gewerbetreibende nicht für unternehmer
was bedeutet das für arbeitsplätze und
ein guter politiker der kann natürlich
dass nicht nur eindimensional betrachten
sondern der muss immer mehrere
perspektiven einnehmen und die dann
abwägen und mir hat während der korona
phase häufig dieser mehrdimensionale
blick gefehlt das war dann immer sehr
einseitig virologisch hätte ich mir
gewünscht dass man vielleicht manchmal
häufiger auftaucht ob virologen wie
henrik strikt gehört hätte sie haben das
thema popularität angesprochen wir haben
ja gesehen dass in den umfragen auch die
wöchentlich mit dem institut durchführen
über wochen karl lauterbach der
beliebteste minister war auch noch vor
olaf scholz mittlerweile liegen annalena
baerbock und robert habeck vorne dann
kommt der bundeskanzler und bär im
rahmen platz nation platz sechs bewegt
sich mittlerweile karl lauterbach also
treibt ihnen das um das er da abgestürzt
ist hat harald martenstein recht wenn er
sagt es geht ihm darum einfach auch
wieder in die öffentlichkeit zu kommen
dinge jetzt nicht nach nicht aufklären
zu wollen um dann im herbst ein hartes
regime wieder führen zu können genau
also ich glaube er vom lehrer genießt
zum einen die popularität die er
zwischenzeitlich hatte die hat er durch
corona das ist ganz klar so ohne krone
wäre er nicht gesundheitsminister
geworden tatsächlich und dann müsse man
offen aussprechen er hat offensichtlich
angst dass bei dieser evaluierung dieser
rauskommt dass diese maßnahmen nicht
sinnvoll waren geschadet haben finde ich
verhältnismäßig waren was auch
verfassungsrechtlicher sehr relevant ist
weil die maßnahmen im verhältnismäßig
und sinnvoll sein müssen was eigentlich
sogar konkret bewiesen werden muss und
das wäre ja eben eigentlich der sinn
einer solchen untersuchung und genau ich
glaube auch er schied auf den nächsten
herbst hat schon wieder irgendwie sich
überlegt was da an verschärfung wieder
kommen könnte unserem alter und die kann
er nicht so ohne weiteres durchsetzen
wenn jetzt eine solche untersuchung im
dazwischen hagelt und das ist das
problem wieso gibt es eigentlich von der
union kein ausschuss keine forderung
nach einem untersuchungsausschuss
in sachen corona krone auf arbeit und
christian ditter hat auch wahlkampf
gemacht mit der forderung das mystery
umwelt es müsse nach dem nach der
bundestagswahl nach der ende der korona
pandemie ein untersuchungsausschuss ein
parlamentarischer viele dinge erinnern
vielleicht zu christian lehnert und der
fdp da gibt es ja in christian lindner 1
und christian lindner 2 den christian
linder 1 das war der vor der wahl der
auch viele gute sachen gefordert hatte
und für die ihr wahlkampf gemacht hat
beispielsweise einhaltung der
schuldenbremse nicht immer mehr schulden
machen reform in der rentenpolitik und
auch bei corona maß und mitte zu wahren
da gab es viele sinnvolle vorschläge
davon wird nur leider jetzt gar nichts
umgesetzt bei christian lindner 2 gibt
es eine komplett gegenteilige politik
ich persönlich bin aber der meinung dass
wir in dieser ausserordentlichen
krisenzeit jetzt auch wirklich
überparteilich alle kräfte darauf
bündeln sollten die aussenpolitischen
krisen bestmöglich zu überwinden und ein
untersuchungsausschuss der kostet viel
zeit der kostet viel kraft der kostet
viele ressourcen deswegen wäre ich eher
der meinung dass man sagen muss was
können wir aus den vorhergegangenen
wellen lernen was bedeutet eine jetzige
evaluation und wie können wir
bestmöglich gerüstet dann in den herbst
gehen